hello everyone thank you for joining us
4cm second annual virtual symposium
advances in drug discovery and
development on Mitch Garcia an assistant
editor at CDN and I'm delighted to
introduce our next speaker who is Hagel
I sofiane from bind therapeutics dr.
Youssef ian has served as fine
therapeutics chief medical officer since
November 2014 edition Lee has led
regulatory affairs and quality assurance
activities since March 2015 dr e sofiane
will be presenting a top type entitled
developing accurate nanomedicines a bind
therapeutic approach i'll be back to
madhuri a Q&A session may be following
the presentation we welcome you to to
ask your questions at any time just
click the green Q&A button in the left
corner of your screen and if you need
any technical assistance during the
presentation please click on the support
button located top right of your screen
please note that CN does not endorse any
company products or services that may be
mentioned in this presentation finally
this talk will be archived and available
on demand at the conference website for
three months after the live broadcast
until December 16 2015 and now I'm he
lied to hand it over to dr. you Sophia
well thank you very much Mitch I
appreciate being able to present you
some data from our company bind
therapeutics and equally share some
ideas around nanomedicines and nano
therapeutic development which I
certainly feel is a significant
opportunity to bring something unique
patients suffering from a variety of
illnesses in our own taste our focuses
clinical oncology but in fact
nanomedicines have numerous potential
applications oncology being just one but
the examples that I'm going to use today
are based on our own experience
primarily in the oncology realm so bind
has been
now a public entity for several years we
are a clinical-stage company our sole
focus is the development of specific
targeted I daresay unique and
proprietary nanoparticles we call them
accurate and so a schematic of that is
shown on the first slide let me go on to
a first remind you that I will be making
forward-looking statements in this
presentation which for a full
description of it you are welcome to
consult our SEC filings and with that
obligation out of the way let me start
with presentation so nanomedicine
development pathway has a number of
similarities to the development of small
molecules the development of biologics
conceptually it's the same pathway
identifying something that one thanks
would make a difference in terms of the
biology of the disease and also
identifying an important unmet medical
need in which to apply the discovery in
that knowledge where nanomedicine
perhaps differs from some of the other
disciplines is that certainly is a
convergence of lots of different
Sciences chemistry and engineering being
two of the more prominent ones but with
regard to relative importance we at
least at bind emphasize engineering and
the way in which will make our
nanoparticles the signs some of the
surface charge characteristics
the fusion properties are all
fundamental engineering issues that are
more relevant to nanotechnology
development than chemistry per se
chemistry is still quite important but
at least in our case we don't
necessarily attempt to optimize the API
or the drug product that is embedded in
the nanoparticle that we assume has been
done to some extent already by our
partners and so what we bring to the
table is the ability to a a first of all
improved some very basic pharmacokinetic
characteristics of a molecule that may
suffer from from those kinds of
challenges and make its by a
distribution much more predictable
improved with therapeutic index by
limiting exposure to help you tissues
and specifically or more specifically
concentrating a drug at the set of
disease but also quite importantly nano
therapeutic development and nanomedicine
is not a a very new idea it's been
around for a number of years and it's
been pursued by many very content
academic groups and also in civil
companies where we think we can make a
difference on the industry side is with
process development and scale-up in the
academic world many innovative
directions are being taken but to
operationalize it to scale it up so that
one can conduct clinical trials
eventually
lead the drug towards approval in one or
more indications and commercialize it
that requires the very disciplined
process development approach that
companies such as ours of Brent to the
table so they're going to emphasize that
this is a multidisciplinary effort but
at least in our case engineer plays a
particularly prominent role so one of
the most challenging issues in any drug
development of words to again to control
the by distribution of the therapeutic
agent to to Aunt apply the presence of
the drug in sight of disease and can
minimize the exposure of a healthy
tissue to a potentially toxic agent so
here's a contrast of sorts with a
conventional oncology therapeutic if one
were to administer this it doesn't
really matter how but let's say
intravenously a drug like the people
that I'm going to be discussing those
shortly docetaxel distributes widely
sought it has a high volume of
distribution and the circulating head
pipe is also very short and it's not
necessarily the case that those attacks
oil is enriched in the tumor it also
goes to kidney liver lung etc so
invariably there's a significant amount
of exposure to healthy tissue and this
is primarily the problem that a very
effective drug like those exacta and
those are taxol presents to oncologists
and that although it is a fact
the therapeutic window is relatively
narrow and so what we hope to accomplish
with our nanoparticles and we call them
accurate is to effect and we'll targeted
delivery and enrichment around the site
of the tumor now you can see on the
right side of this figure that there is
still some green dots that are
distributed systemically but the
difference is possibly an old room or a
magnitude difference so there's a great
enrichment within the tumor and a
relative sparing of healthy tissue what
that also does is to increase the
circulating half-life of the drug so
there's a more of a continuous beeping
of the tumor with the nanoparticle
loaded drug so what our accurint
accurint are polymeric nanoparticles
that have separate really important
components and one comment began to
underscore is that virtually only thing
we use at bind therapeutics has been in
patients already and has been validated
to some extent so that the risk of
development is somewhat lessened by
virtue of the fact that those are
validated components and what we aim to
do is to use poly lactic acid or PLA
which is and of the fda-approved polymer
that has been in patients and after
infusion the poly lactic acids the grace
to lactic acid and it's cleared by the
Krebs cycle so normal metabolic
processes take care of that particular
component and it's nothing unusual that
he hasn't seen before so this is an
fda-approved polymer and what it does
for us is that it allows us to entrap a
payload I mentioned docetaxel several
times but it doesn't have to be
docetaxel could be a variety of other
biological interesting payloads in trap
that the entrapment in this case is not
covalent so we are not modifying those
attacks all or any of the payload
components per se not modifying them
chemically not until coupling it to the
PLA except in this non covalent way we
also take pains to engineer the
nanoparticles so that they are leaking
but not the in an unpredictable way so
there is a regulated release of payload
over days the other the second component
is therapeutic payload or the API and
again this could be a broad range of
payloads the first entry to clinic is
bind or 14 which is loaded with
docetaxel but it could also be peptides
proteins and nucleic acids so there may
be a number of different payloads a
number of clever ways of delivering
therapeutics that have challenges that I
alluded to previously use again it's
important to note that there's no
chemical modification of any of these
tables be it does more molecule or a
biologic the third component is a
polyethylene glycol now there's there's
actually a very important reason why we
use Peck to quote this a PLA that is
now containing a drug and which is the
following that if we left it on its own
without the coating it with pack that
looks like a something that the immune
system could clear it very readily it's
a hydrophobic entity and easily
recognized by immune cells and cleared
very quickly the tag introduces a
hydration shell around the particle and
it makes it look like a water molecule
essentially so that it stays in the
circulation of much longer and it's also
now protected against immune clearance
and the fourth component that is unique
to a platform that we work with is to
introduce a targeting ligand for
targeting to a cells that express a
particular receptor and this can lead to
enhanced particle accumulation at the
side of the disease that it could lead
to cellular uptake and internalization
of the nanoparticle oboe and this is a
very important distinction from antibody
drug conjugates this is not a
requirement at all the targeting ligand
receptor system could be a you know when
we have many choices but the one that is
in clinic now is a PS m8 ligand which is
also a ligand receptor pair that has
clinical validation so the key points
that I'd like to underscore here is that
the nanoparticle is made up of several
component parts all of which
have been validated and together they
constitute essentially a new molecular
entity that we hope will be more than
some of its parts so challenges with
small molecule drugs that can be
addressed by nanotechnology are the
following and in the small molecule
world having something that is a very
high molecular weight or its hydrophobic
or insoluble usually that suitable
molecule is destined to not being
advanced this probably going to end up
in the best bit so it's not an ideal
profile for a conventional drug
candidate but this actually makes it a
very attractive for us and it's a
suitable payload for an accurate why the
relatively large size of the molecule
ensures a complete presence within a
narrow particle as opposed to a very
rapid leakage from the nanoparticle the
hydrophobic nature of an API makes it
compatible with the lipid the lactic
acid moiety of PLA and lastly if a drug
is insoluble in circulation the
nanoparticle entrapment overcomes that
and once that the ones that drug the now
reaches the right environment then
access to tumor tissue or to diseased
tissue is is
enhanced so that the solubility during a
circulation is no longer relevant so
those are three major challenges in
traditional drug development that can be
addressed by nanotechnology but that is
not to say that the battle drugs are the
only ones that we can actually work with
so our scientists have also figured out
ways of really broadening this
therapeutic window that I mentioned
earlier with payloads that have more
favorable intrinsic characteristics so
for example if a drug is not you know
terribly in soluble or if it's not very
hydrophobic but it's cationic well to
make it enter and be compatible with PLA
in that hydrophobic environment what our
scientists can do is the introduce a
counter ion and so now it becomes a
neutral hydrophobic I am here so this is
also something that we have published
and in with some of our collaborations
with former partners we've been able to
generate these kinds of nanoparticles so
again there's no requirement no need a
photo chemical modification and it leads
to the development of a molecule that is
a good but perhaps not good enough and
it allows us to take advantage of the
targeting characteristics of a
nanoparticle to afford to improve that
therapeutic window
so there are two fundamental mechanisms
through which we target Network
nanoparticles what is a mechanism called
EPR or enhanced permeation of attention
and this is something that applies to
liposomes it also applies to
nanoparticles and it has to do with the
large pore sizes and the leaky
vasculature that are part and parcel of
the tumor microenvironment so
nanoparticles gain entry into the tumor
environment by more readily scaping
through these leaky vessels so that's a
PR and the way we think about it is that
this is fundamentally a tissue targeting
now we go a step beyond that and that
actually is achieved by taking advantage
of well understood receptor ligand
players to engineer our nanoparticles
and as I mentioned our first entry in
the clinic was with the PSM a targeted
ligand and in fact here in this
xenograft model we show the same tumor
on on one side which is designated by
that negative symbol that this tumor
which is a prostate cancer tumor is not
expressing psma so the particle still
shows differential accumulation in the
tumor that is not expressing the target
of interest however if we not end that
target which is BS MA and
shown on the contralateral side with the
plus symbol now we see even a greater
accumulation of the nanoparticle so that
allows us to say that both the EPR
effect and a specific ligand receptor
targeting are both relevant and
desirable with certain tables this may
or may not be necessary with all
payloads but again our first entry in
the clinic leverages both tissue and
ligand and cell-cell you're targeting so
the engineering approach that we follow
here uses a variety of dials to
establish the optimal particle size the
ligand density and the API load but of
course it doesn't stop there so our
engineers and generate several different
versions of a nanoparticle that is truly
a collaboration with our biology group
to figure out which one then which
particle with certain diffusion
characteristics gives the best outcome
in our animal models so so far that is
somewhat predictable but also empirical
so we actually end up testing sometimes
three four different metal particles
before going back to the engineering
group and saying that make more of this
this is what we want this is one wanted
nominated for development
on the toxicology side one might think
that there would be differences in the
toxicity to of different nanoparticles
with different fusion diffusion
characteristics what I can say clearly
is that the empty nanoparticle by itself
is actually quite a benign there's very
little toxicity associated with it at
any so so the empty nanoparticle is
non-toxic so whatever toxicity we
observe is therefore directly
attributable to the payload and the
diffusion characteristics that are
embedded in that nanoparticle well so
the way we think about nanoparticle
development here is that with our first
entry with an approved drug we have an
opportunity to differentiate it from the
parent drug and we also are in a very
good position of working with a
validated drug we know where to go in
clinic which to attach to pursue so so
in a sense this is differentiated
efficacy with approved Russ the next
stage that we're exploring now is to
allow us to probe other pathways with
inhibitors that may be highly potent
they're generally ones that involve well
understood the mechanisms in cancer
biology but their toxicity may be
severely limiting and therefore
resulting in a very narrow therapeutic
windows so this is what we'd like to
overcome and thirdly we're also now
exploring a break to it there is so to
speak therapies with oligonucleotides as
payloads therapies in the immune
oncology arena where we can also utilize
the kinds of targeting ideas that we've
been learning through our current effort
so to talk more about where we are now
in clinic let me just take you through
bind to 14 this is again the PSM a
directed now particle that is loaded
with docetaxel so you can see two
examples here of private hands in that
first bucket with no unapproved drugs
docetaxel is the one in clinic we've
also made inroads with vincristine which
is a microtubule inhibitor somewhat
similar to docetaxel mechanistically but
not exactly and both are very potent
drugs but the toxicity can be
prohibitive here you can see that would
bind a 14 hour clinical candidate in in
a model versus docetaxel there is a very
good activity with the nanoparticle
better what I've done with docetaxel and
with bind 5 10 5 5 10 is the
nanoparticle loaded with then Christine
there's also improved activity with the
nanoparticle version versus the free
drug in the panel below you can also see
PK data of x over 4 and the prolong PK
lasting over days is also a
characteristic of our nanoparticles and
sometimes the PK dipper so in this case
Oh 14 spk is different from 5-10 spk but
that is also something that now needs to
be juxtaposed to the biology experiments
to determine which one yields the most
optimal biological effect so to take you
through the clinical development to date
we have probably treated over 160 k
shins with by door 14 initially this
drug went through a dose escalation
study and the dose that we identified
for phase 2 development was 60
milligrams per meter squared
administered every three weeks
intravenously it was actually important
for us to identify that particular
schedule when we through week
administration because that's how does
it taxol is administered clinic and we
thought that in the future if we need to
do a head-to-head comparison it would be
important to minimize the variables so
at the same time we had studied a weekly
schedule but we decided to invest every
three weeks schedule for that reason but
also importantly with the every two
weeks schedule we began to season
responses and sometimes very interesting
responses so for example we had a
patient with cervical cancer who after
a number of prior therapies had a
complete response complete eradication
of all the tumor deposits that she had
so this was a very gratifying outcome
for us but we also had responses than
patients with lung cancer prostate
cancer and biliary tract cancer now many
of those tumors and Pat do respond to
docetaxel so from that perspective it
was not a huge surprise that we should
see Kansas City I said we should see
activity in those tumor settings but
nonetheless this was the first
opportunity for this novel targeted
nanoparticle to be tested in patients so
we were already seeing activity at this
very early stage we also saw a number of
stable disease that in a number of
patients which is also an indication of
clinical activity now I won't dwell on
the pharmacokinetics but suffice it to
say that the AUC is much improved versus
that of free docetaxel and it's also
really does proportional so all of the
behaviors inside the body as as the now
particle is circulating is a very
predictable and generally speaking at
any point in time over the course of
let's say a days to a week or more about
90% ninety two percent of the
circulating drug in this case those
attacks though is actually encapsulated
so that there's any free circulating
docetaxel it's in minority
now one of the total concept
opportunities for us was to understand
the targeting aspects dimension before
and the dual targeting mechanism the EPR
effect and via cellular target so we're
still doing a lot of work in this area
but we are increasingly appreciating
that the tumor vasculature is important
for targeting nanoparticles it's
important and perhaps quite intuitive in
terms of the epr of that but in terms of
PSMA expression there is a fascinating
story here so PSMA was initially
discovered in the context of prostate
cancer and that's where actually the
name comes from so prostate cancer cells
per se express PSMA but when we're
staying activity is outside of prostate
cancer and it turns out that rarely is
psma expressed our tumors like lung
cancer tumors or cholangiocarcinoma that
I mentioned previously however the Neil
vasculature associated with those tumors
and endothelial cells lining up those
tumors are actually PS and they positive
and so that is in fact we think what's
happening here that the nanoparticle is
going to the right place in the tumor
and being targeted to Tacoma through
both the EPR effect and through the
presence of psma on a tumor-associated
vasculature
so based on that successful app come
from case one we then enter a phase 2
development and we tested the drug in an
open-label study in 40 patients with
second line non-small cell lung cancer
the dose and schedule of the drug that
we used came exactly out of our phase
one study and in this study we were also
very interested in first understanding
whether we have a drug here for further
development but also that we could
further validate their platform from
from a clinical standpoint then you
think that we are well underway here so
let me take you through some of the
phase one data we saw a clinical
activity in this tough to treat patient
population and so specifically we saw
six partial responses or fifteen percent
overall response rate among fully
patients now we believe that that is
meaningful because the typical response
rate with docetaxel is in the single
digits let's say five to eight percent
and we were saying these responses
despite a reduction of twenty percent in
the dose of the payload so docetaxel
typically is administered at 75
milligrams per meter squared whereas the
dose that would use in without now
particles in 60 millimeter square so
despite that twenty percent reduction in
the dose we're seeing activity that we
think is above and beyond what we should
be able to see what those attacks though
very importantly also the tolerability
of now particle appears to be much
better than that of the parent drug war
sweet asset here so if I could call your
attention to the table on the right side
of the slide we're comparing adverse
events in this trial with bible on 42
the adverse events in second line lung
cancer patients who are treated with tax
appear and those numbers actually come
out of the tacit ear fda-approved label
if you look at hematologic toxicities
for example anemia anyway twenty percent
would bite or 14 ninety-one percent
would have SAT here celosa substantial
difference no statistical statistician
needed I suppose it's also the case for
other hematologic toxicities and for
some non hematologic toxicities as well
now the criticisms the criticism that
could be made with these data is that
these trials were done you know several
years apart there could be differences
in support of care all of which is quite
legitimate but if you scroll down in
that same table to alopecia or hair loss
with binder one for fifteen percent
would tax it here fifty-six percent and
of course there's no supportive care
involved there so it's a clean beat out
of what's going on at the healthy tissue
level and this is the kind of data that
gives us a a lot of excitement and hope
that the platform is performing as we
had predicted namely its resulting in
the substantial activity that i
mentioned before but it's also sparing
healthy tissue
now without sense probably only some of
you may be experts in lung cancer let me
just take a little quick interlude to
say that lung cancer space treatment the
classification has become quite
sophisticated now it's based on
histology it's based on molecular
characteristics so it's no longer a
single disease entity so even though our
trial was done in a population that is
essentially a real world patient
population we were actually very pleased
to see that in two large subgroups of
lung cancer goes with kayla's mutated
tumors and those with squamous cell
histology there was also substantial
activity and both of those subtypes are
ones that are notoriously difficult to
treat in fact for kayla's mutant tumors
there is no approved therapy
specifically for that genotype for
tumblers with squamous histology and the
second line setting until a few months
ago there was nothing specifically
approved now with op depot which is BMS
is anti pd-1 antibody there is
unfortunately something available to
patients but it's only the minority of
the patients that benefit from that
therapy so there's still a lot of room
for improvement and here's the data that
I just alluded to let me just make one
other point here which is that our trial
so far have been single on trial so
these are not randomized trials
therefore the comparison is and variably
to historical data
but there's also very good historical
data so with Kara's mutant tumors
another drug dab is now in Bay Street
development or compared the combination
of that drug to docetaxel versus
docetaxel and the response rate with
docetaxel was 0% what we saw in our case
was a total of three responses in nine
patients or so we're quite intrigued by
that but we'd also like to continue our
study in chaos mutant tumors and so that
we'll have a we'll have more confidence
in taking next steps and developing a
pivotal trial in that setting in the
squamous histology subtype also we were
very intrigued by the overall survival
outcome of 11.1 months which is quite
interesting especially compared to the
octavo trial that i mentioned that just
received approval in that case of people
was compared to docetaxel and the median
survival on docetaxel was just around
six months which is not that unusual the
additional importance of these data is
not so much that we are getting
clinically superior results but perhaps
even more importantly that the platform
really is performing as we had set up to
as we had anticipated namely resulting
in greater activity versus docetaxel and
lower toxicity now I'm going to take you
quickly through some of the next steps
that we're doing so it's not only
cytotoxic that we can engineer and
nanoparticles but it's also a variety of
very interesting kinase inhibitors some
quite potent such as the Merc compound
where we have a very interesting
collaboration with them there there are
two agents in this collaboration a KSP
inhibitor and plk1 inhibitor both KSP
and plk1 are involved in a cell cycle
control and through a different
collaboration with astrazeneca we
engineered nanoparticles containing an
or the kinase inhibitor which has if is
now being readied for face more
development so those are very exciting
opportunities for us to learn more for
my platform and also to provide
something valuable to our industry
partners and here's one example with the
or the kinase inhibitor on the left you
see that the parent drug versus the
control virtually wipes out the bone
marrow so the blue cells are gone and
that is a classic toxicity that results
from or b kinase inhibitors what would
be aculon it's actually almost
indistinguishable from what's going on
with the control panel especially a
curing too so again to earlier point
that it's protecting a healthy tissue we
believe that this is also the case here
and on the right side one of the several
epica see experiments where accurate two
shows in fact as in tumor with Russians
versus the parent drug so again a very
exciting preclinical data to position it
for clinical development
also importantly more recent studies
that represented at ACR showed activity
in several other models including a
lymphoma model and a small cell lung
cancer model but on the top panel is
what I'd like to call your attention you
can see that with the carrot drug with
the naked or kinase inhibitor did a drug
doesn't really accumulate very
effectively in the tumor and is
essentially not there by 24 hours was
with the accurint formulation we see
drug to essentially almost uniformly
throughout the tumor nine days after
completion of the dose so this again
speaks very powerful in our lines to the
targeting than the location of the drug
within the tumor environment so just to
make that point a little bit more in
terms of the pharmacokinetics we work
with several accurate and we take the
one that would take several actually to
in vivo models so on the right you see a
breast cancer model where with vacuum d
there's a lot more or API in the tumor
on the lower left-hand side this is a
very interesting pharmacodynamic marker
which actually can be dosed limiting for
this class of drugs where you see the
red line showing a vast increase in
glucose levels after treatment but what
the accurate that is essentially
completely ablated so agendas may very
well be a c-max effect that is
completely addressed by the nanoparticle
approach in the last concept that I'd
like to talk to you about is
breakthrough therapies now of course
there are a number of very interesting
additional applications with a Q ants
and what we're doing is shown on this
slide we have a collaboration with
macrophage therapeutics and it's in the
email oncology space now of course have
been substantial inroads into
understanding of checkpoint inhibitors
pd-1 ppl 1 and so on but not nearly as
much than understanding in terms of the
tumor microenvironment and the various
cell types that play very important
roles and in your suppression so one of
the key cell types in the tumor
microenvironment that's involved in in
suppressing host immunity is the
macrophage and their historic can get
quite complicated so let me try to get a
relatively straightforward version of it
there are several different macrophage
types that can be polarized and can go
from one direction to another some of
those subtypes are pro to Merle so
they're obviously bad others can be anti
general and the idea is that if we can
change the pro to Merle macrophages to
become anti Journal that that would
address a very important component of
the tumor microenvironment and allow us
to bring something unique
within the Union oncology area so what
we're doing is that established a
collaboration with macro pitch
therapeutics network th therapeutics is
a very exciting a a partner of Numidia
and the vidya had an imaging agent
called a tool man except which is
fda-approved and the imaging agent is
one that targets CD 206 now CD 206 is
also known as the nanos receptor and its
present on activated or bad macrophages
so we have established this
collaboration with the idea of
engineering on nanoparticles with
mannose receptor directed ligands and
with the earlier earliest stages of this
collaboration but this is a very
exciting opportunity because for the
first time it will allow us to directly
target those cells with payloads and you
can probably think of several potential
payloads but what we're interested in it
to test them in Paraguay so either kill
the bad macrophages through direct
targeting or directly target about
natural pages but allow them to be
forced toward the direction of becoming
antitumoral and so those experiments are
underway and we think that the are now
technology and the accurate platform can
bring something special to the table so
in conclusion and this is a big effort
and of course it involves collaborations
in turn
and with a simple of our current
partners and we're very fortunate to be
collaborating with them the versatility
and the scalability of our Acura
platform we think are very important
differentiating points it allows us to
introduce multiple different
therapeutics including small molecules
nucleic acids and proteins it allows us
to target specific cells with ligands
that may be small molecules but also
with larger molecules peptides and
antibodies and although I've been
discussing cancer biology throughout my
talk this approach is also quite
relevant to other inflammatory and
conditions vascular diseases infectious
diseases final 14 is our first product
to enter clinic it's a novel psma
targeted nanoparticle that contains
those attacks though it is certainly we
believe that the greater efficacy and
tolerability that we've seen with by de
la Warr versus docetaxel allows us to
say that the therapeutic window is being
affected in a meaningful way but also
that the platform is working so our
initial and we believe promising data
has now led to additional trials these
are multicenter phase 2 trials and both
lung cancer and in other tumor types
where we identified that additional
tumors that have
limited at death that that can be
impacted with docetaxel but in a limited
way we now have to have the opportunity
to bring something even more potent
again to impact those tumors and that
lastly our collaborations with
astrazeneca with visor with Roche and
work and with macrophage therapeutics
allows us to broaden our bandwidth
considerably ankle beyond the data they
showed to you already into other very
exciting area so thank you very much
okay thank you use a peon for the talk
there are several questions have come in
so I will ask the first one I i'm going
to synthesize two questions that are
very related this question was from
tarik fidelity and NGO and from William
Litchfield what is the typical size of
these nanoparticles and how do you
ensure that the loading of the payload
is done homogeneously in such a way that
each nanoparticle has more or less the
same amount of API yeah okay so the
typical size of our nanoparticles is
around 100 nano your diameter and the
way we ensure that there is optimal
loading of the nanoparticle with the
payload is it's really bad I forgot
which number slide applies but we are
engineers it very very good at gauging
different payload densities and so some
of this then is a handed over to the
biology group so it's really a cool
operation as to what is that optimum
profile at the end but I would probably
say that with docetaxel there are you
know on your group several paths and
molecules per nanoparticle okay so in
another question this is from Chris
Brown from Ewa tech can the
nanoparticles target the cns or pass
through the blood-brain barrier well
it's a fascinating question logic so
it's so it's a terrific question because
nanoparticles are large molecules we
don't I don't think that they can
readily go through the blood-brain
barrier except that the new vasculature
that is also quite relevant to a tumor
like glioblastoma can be accessed
potentially can be accessed with a psma
directed nanoparticle but in addition
one can also think of other clever
approaches with brain shuttling
molecules for example and so there's a
lot more to be done in that area and a
state job its work in progress so
another question about your nanoparticle
and technology system this is from
shaanxi from katham university could the
technology be developed to work with
more metastatic tumor types such as
lymphoma or melanoma or
so I personally think that there's very
little out there that is beyond the
limits of applying you know really
clever biology and engineering
approaches so there are certain
lymphomas that I think could be accessed
and one piece of data that I showed
before was in a model called diffuse
large b-cell lymphoma dlbcl through our
collaboration with astrazeneca so that
has not yet been tested in patients but
that is the kind of proof of concept
data from preclinical models that gives
me hope that the same would happen in
clinic nella normal likewise I think
should be amenable to those same
approaches so the next question will do
my best to synthesize this as well as
two people had the same question this is
quote from urban or rural from Princeton
Institute of Technology and Patrick
shell from work the question is how
stable are these nanoparticles with
respect to such as particle size of a
pea a leakage and in what environment
are they kept in in order to keep their
there's ability in 10 so again part of
the optimization steps that I discussed
previously involved for all of these
aspects stability you know how fast the
payload diffuses out of the nanoparticle
the pore size etc so I'm afraid there's
not a single answer but in general those
metal particles are very stable on the
clinical side I can tell you that we are
doing a multicenter or global trials and
the you know at least on the clinical
side it's nanoparticles are really quite
user-friendly so this will be the last
question I have for you to today um
there's been a lot of questions about
bandages of using targeting ligand
versus a non targeting ligand I know you
have that one slide showing the
difference comparison but I think people
would like if you could elaborate a
little bit more on that and also what
what details that bandaged up after when
I compared comparison to your Abraxane
is targeting ligand pmsi truly important
for for what's been observed episode so
it's a great question and again it's not
a one size fit all proposition in the
case of I go on for we believe that psma
targeting is actually playing an
important role in tumors outside of
prostate cancer now with regard to
abraxane actually a precedent is not a
targeted particle but the the tag
coating you know quickly comes off after
infusion it's basically there to to
obviate the need for chemical which is a
solvent let's say that is associated
with hypersensitivity so that's that's
all instilling in our case the tech is
forming a protective shield and
improving the biodistribution of the
nanoparticle so conceptualist it's
different also with liposomes i want to
generate indiana liposomes but it's
generally very difficult to introduce
targeting components on liposomes with
our technology
or go there are several components it's
actually all assembled in a single step
so this is part of the intellectual
property that we have that makes it very
very difficult from some of the other
approaches so I hope it then that means
partially answers that very good
question so that's all the time we have
many thanks to dr. you sofiane for your
presentation and thanks to you all for
tuning in there will be more great talks
beginning at the top that our throughout
the rest of the day you can find a full
program on the agenda page located at
the upper right-hand side of your screen
in the meantime please stop by the
virtual exhibit hall and allows to check
out our sponsors and exhibitors our
network of other attendees during the
conversation on twitter with hashtag cen
715 and if dr. yusuf ian has anything
less parting comments to say I'll pass
it over to them today I'll pass it along
I just like to thank you all for the
opportunity to present key these data we
are certainly excited by our platform
but also very excited that we can
provide I hope in the near future
something meaningful to our patients so
thank you very much all right thank you
and that will conclude the top four
today